dans jurassic world dominion
le parc a disparu
et les dinosaures sont partout
owen claire et maisie vivent hors de
la grille
bleu a eu un bébé c'est impossible
fille
tu ressembles à ta mère
je promets que je vais la récupérer
jurassic world dominion nous a donné l'
opportunité de  emmenez la franchise dans
des endroits nouveaux et différents
je dois réparer une terrible erreur que
je vous ai faite
venir ou ce que
je dois vous avertir tout le monde est tellement excité
de vous avoir vous êtes des
légendes absolues ici nos histoires se
croisent nous arrivons à renouer avec  de vieux
amis et apprendre à connaître de nouveaux amis
on dirait que c'est la fin d'un
chapitre
tu es prêt à risquer ta vie pour des gens que
tu n'as jamais rencontrés
tu veux poser des questions ou tu veux
rouler
j'ai pensé que c'était une idée fantastique d'
amener ces deux  mondes ensemble
j'ai fait une promesse que nous la ramènerions à la maison
tu as fait une promesse
à un dinosaure ouais
pourquoi
la domination du monde jurassique est le
point culminant de la franchise
nous te donnons quelque chose que tu  veux mais
ne t'attends pas à ce
que ce ne soit pas vrai je n'ai jamais vu d'
action comme celle-ci
le dinosaure le plus effrayant et le plus impressionnant est
très similaire
est que
[Musique]
vous